hey guys how's it going happy
Valentine's Day if you celebrate if you
don't it's perfectly fine because it's
dumb anyway but since we're celebrating
this festive holiday Jen's over there
laughing I thought I would make a really
nice emoji kiss face cake where you
making the cake right now
yeah I'm making the cake right now so
let me get all of my supplies we've got
our moist supreme classic cake I ordered
black icing on Amazon because I couldn't
find it anywhere and here we order Erica
skirt it's got its block it's got all of
the things here oh that's new baby oh I
just started 350 I haven't blended
anything in a while oh god oh god
I'm also the Baker in cameraperson
know I could hire someone but then I
have to deal with another person other
than myself i annoy myself already okay
Elysee ah everything is awesome for egg
whites I should probably try to I'm just
going to do three eggs one two three
yeah okay I know I don't measure but I
want this cake to be good 1/2 cup oil 1
cup water ok close I've done yet put our
top on and then we're gonna just give it
a nice blend watches watches watches
cool great story let's what do we got in
a pan do i grease this pan
I never remember well I'm gonna grease
it just to be safe
cuz uh-oh
looks good cool where's the cake come
with ready all right oh oh we did a
double decker no it's a single deck all
right so I got my cake I'm gonna put
this into the oven and let this cook for
how many minutes up too many minutes are
you at 350 yet I think you are you're
good enough let's put this in all right
cool set my alarm for 30 minutes
all right look at the cake cook and then
we'll decorate
so since this is an emoji cake I'm going
to need yellow icing so to make yellow
icing I'm going to use yellow food
coloring and put it into the icing this
is really riveting and new technology so
let's put our creamy supreme vanilla
frosting into a nice Bowl it's better be
yellow yellow and like so give it a
little mix we prep it looks great this
is beautiful this is so emoji yellow I
can't even handle it oops just
splattered food coloring all over the
place looks like we've got our icing
nicely mixed up so our cake should be
done here very soon and we'll ice it up
and decorate beautiful
here's our cake it's time to decorate
pretty excited I think it looks so
turned out well there's a big hump on it
here so I think I'm just going to kind
of just flip it and decorate the nice
half whoa oh yes well stuck in there
you're stuck I'll get you out of there
oh you look good you look so nice
this cake is gonna be delicious I got I
gotta cut this bottom part because it's
a little too too little too uh puffy
oops
hi do you want this yeah can you just
take it away then there you go so we're
gonna ice this up here with our
beautiful yellow icing and then we
decorate just put this icing right on
here I'll save a little bit just in case
I need to do some stuff
alright we got a little slice an dice I
need to double-check and see what this
emoji looks like so that I can get it
right I can do this I'm so nervous
let's see I'll draw the eye first okay
this icing was not a good idea I thought
it would be but it's not it's still hard
to control
yeah right work
the eyebrows a little big it's a little
big it's okay No
here it is so now the real test is what
is Matt and Jenna think looks good
uh do you hate it that's all bad cut
this woman looks good huh yeah it's
great
it tastes great I didn't mess it up
tastes fantastic
they set the star birthday exact same
case yeah I cooked it a little longer by
accident I just really like I'm saying
this is a great taste thank you guys for
watching let me know what you'd like me
to cook next leave me a comment below
don't forget to subscribe for more
wonderful video and somebody for my
trans hmm will do not talk about the
churros yeah this is a great taste look
big battery completely mess guys like my
new unboxing table can you tell it's a
little different